usted va a ser este discurso bien
recibido por parte de los
estadounidenses en cuanto al tema
económico sí que realmente compran este
discurso de un mejoramiento en la
economía Por supuesto que no Por
supuesto que no puesto que el 7
0% de los encuestados estadounidenses
han dicho que están peor con Joe biden
que cuando empezó el mandato con Trump
que vamos a hablar de Trump y trajo los
índices de desempleo a mínimos
históricos entre las minorías entre la
población fíjense una cosa Claro que sí
que estamos mejor 13 de las 15 13 de los
15 primeros estados de Estados Unidos
con la tasa de desempleo más bajas
gobernada por los republicanos nada que
agradecer al Gobierno Federal sino a
nuestros gobernadores nueve de los diez
primeros estados en recuperación de
empleo gobernado Por los republicanos
ahora Eso sí recuerden 27 de los 30
estados con mayores tasas de asesinatos
gobernados por los demócratas Mira
estuardo lo que pasa es que los números
También hablan y lo que hablan es que lo
único que hace el Gobierno Federal es
llevarnos unos límites de gastos
insostenibles Claro que por supuesto
hace un comentario Joe biden de que
luego los distritos gobernados Por los
republicanos nos gastamos el dinero y
invertimos claro que sí pues sabemos
manejar la economía pero vamos lo que sí
te tengo que totalmente dejar claro es
que yo biden no ha invertido
absolutamente nada en la frontera hasta
dos años y medio después de que estos de
que esto estallera la crisis en la
frontera y nada más O sea así que
simplemente es un partido un partido
demócrata y una administración que
quiere violar los derechos individuales
retirar las armas no solo las armas como
ellos le dicen de asalto que por cierto
ni se llaman armas de asalto se llaman
son tildas de otra de otra forma sino
simplemente lo único que quieren es
retirar los derechos individuales y
venderte por supuesto lo mismo que
siempre el socialismo de Venezuela y los
demás países que ellos van a proteger a
los trabajadores las minorías y nada más
Pero vamos que no hay no hay no hay nada
de fondo